every time Apple unveils a new version
of this compatible cases pop up online
sometimes before the new iPhone even
ships on the day Apple unveiled the
iPhone 14 these cases were ready for you
to do this
but how do these case makers know
something we don't here's what's going
on behind the scenes some work with
inside sources iPhones are in
development for years before they come
out and apple doesn't actually build
everything in-house it relies on
third-party manufacturers around the
world a lot of assembly happens in China
and information about what Apple's
cooking up often leaks and that's what
many case makers rely on they speak to
the factories directly and work with
Consultants who somehow have inside
knowledge about what Apple's working on
companies like Peak design say going
this route requires a good amount of
guessing and risk the factories that we
utilize and really I think all factories
that are that have been making phone
cases for a while they somehow acquire
information with a certain level of
confidence we don't know where they get
their information from and frankly we
just have to trust them really quite
blindly Peak design spent tens of
thousands on material and hundreds of
thousands on inventory months before
Apple released its newest phone there
simply are no guarantees until those
phones are shipping it's pretty hefty
Financial Risk even companies that make
materials for cases try to anticipate
when Apple's cooking up we never know if
the new iPhone is going to be square
around so if it's going to skinny or
it's going to be heavy so we need to
plan for all eventualities so that our
customers have got the right material
the right time if case makers guess
correctly they're on store shelves when
the new iPhone launches if they're wrong
the case might not fit your phone to
mitigate the risk companies often leave
literal space to be wrong so the holes
for the camera and spaces for buttons
and speakers are often bigger than
what's actually necessary but not
everyone plays the guessing game some
work directly with apple apple sells
cases by other accessory makers
including Belkin OtterBox and Tech21
analysts say apple likely chooses
Partners known for their premium
products and what they don't want to do
is be associated with some cheap
accessories batter box cases launched
with the new iPhone go for 49.95 wow
this one from Belkin is 39.95 it's about
the customer and about giving them some
limited choice to make them feel good
about owning Apple products I ask these
companies how much they know in advance
and they either didn't respond or
couldn't discuss particular Partnerships
but how quickly they can turn around
cases still matters Belkin designs
engineers and test samples in-house
which speeds up the production process
it can go from Hey I was talking to
Dalvin about this case today to wow
tomorrow I've got it in my hand analysts
say it's generally beneficial to have
your cases sold on Apple's website
because when people are checking out a
new iPhone it's easy for them to add a
case to the cart still Apple ensures its
own products are a priority I noticed
all its partners are buried below all
these Apple branded products but the
company declined to comment and then for
other companies it's not worth the risk
to be first they wait until the new
iPhone is released they stand in line
like the rest of us to buy phones so
they can test their products directly on
them the day Apple releases a new iPhone
it publishes specs including the
dimensions
companies like Catalyst use this
information to start working on rugged
cases and once they have a few phones in
hand testing begins we have to make sure
that the devil is in the details and we
get everything exactly right so
Precision really matters the benefits of
testing against the actual phone are
twofold one case makers know exactly
what they're working against and can
create specialized cases that help to
justify a heftier price tag and two by
the time your old case starts yellowing
and looking gross these are on the
shelves on the flip side since iPhones
tend to come out in September they risk
missing out on the holiday Gadget buying
season which means they have a shorter
window to release cases before the next
iPhone comes out I know you're probably
more concerned about what features will
be baked into the year's hottest phone
but the market for accessories including
cases will continue to grow through
2030. the case you choose has a
backstory and regardless of what case
that is any case is better than no case